oportunidad voy a darle la palabra ahora
a María Herrera sobre las primeras
impresiones del discurso de Joe biden
Bueno antes que hablar del discurso que
que comentar lo que ha dicho mi
compañero no hablar de democracia cuando
es un partido
demócrata y un presidente baile que
ataca a la otra mitad del país y que lo
tilda de supremacista o que quiera
ampliar el tribunal supremo como en
Venezuela o que dice que los jueces del
tribunal supremo son antidemócratas por
respetar la Constitución y acabar con el
derecho que no Es legal constitucional
al aborto para devolvérselo a los
Estados Pues nada que Añadir Por
supuesto que ellos son los más
anticonstitucionales y más
antidemócratas y ni mencionar aquellos
gobernadores y demócratas que dejan de
cumplir la ley que han hecho que 27 de
las 30 ciudades más peligrosas de los
Estados Unidos sean gobernadas por ellos
por la izquierda la extrema izquierda
que quiere dejar de cumplir y del
legalizar lo que es los delitos
agravados consumo de droga tráfico de
sustancia prostitución etcétera mire lo
que está pasando en Nueva York
California ni somos un país que estamos
en un momento fuerte ni podemos ser
optimistas cuando como yo comenzaba al
inicio del debate pues no se ha tratado
la crisis inmigratoria en la peor crisis
migratoria desde que se fundó el
Ministerio de seguridad nacional
vergüenza le tenía que dar al secretario
mayorca de los que además estuvo en
Miami hace una semana no sabe dónde han
ido un millón 600.000 inmigrantes que se
han perdido entrando en la frontera por
por cierto muchos de ellos más de 100
terroristas en la lista de terroristas
ni son el partido de los trabajadores ni
quieren proteger a las minorías Porque
si quisieran defender a los trabajadores
y a las minorías lo que ha dicho
absolutamente falso lo que tienen que
hacerle es dar la libertad y no obligar
a miles de trabajadores a vacunarse y
inocularse algo que el tribunal
constitucional de los Estados Unidos
también ha declarado y constitucional
qué más poder decir más mentiras que ha
dicho el presidente biden que las
grandes empresas no pagan impuestos
miren los datos son claros vayan a la
fundación
de estudios de impuestos algo que estas
personas no conocen porque no saben cómo
llevar absolutamente nada impuestos sino
ganar impuestos a las personas para
robarlo y luego distribuirlo entre los
que ellos dicen pobres Pero simplemente
para sacar más ayuda las empresas en
Estados Unidos y los empresarios son los
que más impuestos pagan en este país un
tercio de los impuestos lo pagan los más
ricos de este país porque crean empleos
porque pagan los impuestos de los
trabajadores Y qué más decir de ese
Border plan que es absolutamente nefasto
inexistente Y qué vergüenza le debería
dar a biden cuando han testificado sus
agentes de la patrulla fronteriza del
sector de tuso que han reconocido que
los carteles de la droga absolutamente
tiene el control de nuestras fronteras
Así que nada positivo acerca de este
discurso